[Applause]
this has been a fantastic year for
Cinema I mean the the movies across the
board were extraordinary anatomy of a
fall past lives uh Barbie with great
movies and all different in their own
way but bringing something authentic I
turned 60 today it's the second most
epic birthday of my life the first was
the most epic I just am viewing this as
a kind of a surrealist felini birthday
60th birthday
party you're so exciting what a way to
start the new year um my first time here
so I feel really grateful and it's just
exciting to feel the energy feel um
really grateful to be in um in this
company you know what I mean it's uh
it's a great great year it's a it's a
big year and this is all quite
intimidating but it's a good
intimidation well I mean I think a part
of it is being a firsttime filmmaker
it's the part of it is like I it's the
you know I don't know if I can say
anything sweeping about the industry in
that way but I do know that I've been
feeling so welcomed and I've been
feeling so like all of this is feeling
so effortless with me and uh this movie
and I think in that way I just really uh
I don't know I love this so much and I
it's been was such an honor to be
nominated as a director you know so
cool I'm so excited to be here it's it's
wonderful we come with this small and
shy Little Love Story from Finland and
we're invited here and to celebrate
movies and there's a lot of lots of
reasons to celebrate tonight I
guess
I